we've told this story before we've told
the story before of when i trashed
uh bishop briggs's
uh
trailer and oh totally by accident it
was not my fault but i don't know if i
told you but
yes it kind
of fault she asked for a topo chico i
went to open the topo chico and the
whole cabinet came flying down it was my
fault it's kind of not how it went
she was insistent that she was so proud
that that she had the topo chico that's
what she was loving she loved her
trailer and she got all the type of
chico she could drink and she kept
insisting you guys need to take one you
need to take one well it was it was not
a screw cab
so brad's like uh you know the old
college you put it on the side of the
table and you hit uh-huh and you pop and
they broke the table
the whole front of the table came
crashing down
the other train
no no i was opening it for her i was
being a gentleman i said would you like
to have a topo chico miss miss bishop
briggs and i went to open it and then it
it
broke the place in half and then i was
like i'll just get you another one i'll
get you another one and then i went back
to the topo chico stack opened it it
flew out of my hand got choked pochico
everywhere on the thing
she just looked down at the ground in a
toppo chico covered ground and a bottle
that was sprawled over there
and she just looked at me and she goes
uh
just go just go yeah you're like i'll
clean it up i'll clean it up she said
just go
i couldn't pack ups or stuff quickly
enough just go
i so i i ran into her in the city a
couple of weeks ago and i uh i brought
that story up to her and she goes do you
know what i haven't had a topo chico
since
they're ruined forever now
she literally looked at me and it's like
i think that was the last table chick
that i'll ever drink in my life
i have the bottle
it's in my collection of bonner stuff
send me a picture of it i'll text it to
her that's fantastic i'll send it to
taco well i need to include it in the uh
in the video here yeah yeah i tossed it
in the video right here
it was not one of my finer moments but
it was not my fault
it was a shoddy construction of a
cabinet that should not have been
breaking just because i was trying to
open a bottle okay well
she had nothing to open the top of that
i needed to be
the big strong man for her it was pretty
funny she's pregnant too by the way
she's about to uh have a baby beautiful
pregnant i mean she is that's not your
fault either though
i would that was definitely not mine
either